be sure to subscribe to lange focus and
click the notification button hello
everyone welcome to the lange focused
channel and my name is paul today we'll
be talking about languages without verb
tenses languages without ferb tenses
how's that possible
speakers of English and other
indo-european languages and I guess
other languages too might take it for
granted that the basic features of their
language must be present in other
languages as well but that's not always
the case one example of this is verb
tense using a particular form of a verb
to show the time period of an action
past present or future as they exist on
a timeline in English we basically have
these three tenses present tense is
represented by the simple verb stem like
play for example with regular verbs the
past tense is represented by the stem
plus the inflection edie like played and
the simple future tense is formed by
placing the modal auxiliary verb will
before the infinitive which is based on
the verb stem - - for example we'll play
some linguists might argue that this
future form is not actually a verb tense
we'll come back to that later but some
languages don't have verb tenses meaning
they don't have different verb
conjugations to show periods of time
this is true of many Creole languages
for example of Indonesian and Malaysian
of Chinese of many Native American
languages and a lot more here's an
example from Indonesian
here's the verb meaning pay in the past
present and future mumbai odda
the form of the verb is exactly the same
in all three tenses and this might sound
strange to you how can they clearly
communicate without being able to say
when an action takes place well first of
all it's normally not that hard to guess
from context just to illustrate let's
take the English word put which is the
same in the present tense and past tense
I put my keys on the table so as that
sentence of present tense or past tense
in the middle of a story taking place in
the past it would probably be past tense
but if someone were describing that
action as part of their daily after work
routine then it would probably be
present tense context can clarify the
time of an action aside from general
context there are other ways of
indicating when an action takes place
first there are words and expressions
that indicate a specific time that the
action
takes place like today yesterday next
week last year etc second there are
adverbs that indicate aspect for example
Sudha
Mumbai er which basically means already
paid sedan Mumbai er which means in the
process of paying masse Mumbai er which
means still paying these adverbs show
aspect what's the difference between
tense and aspect as I mentioned before
temps indicates the time period of an
action past present or future aspect
deals with the way actions unfold in
relation to the time line rather than
where they occur on the time line
Sudha shows that an action is completed
with a focus on the result of the action
we could call this perfect aspect sadang
marks the imperfective aspect showing
that an action is in progress
but the action is not necessarily in the
present tense Massey also marks the
imperfective aspect showing that an
action is continuing but with an
emphasis on the fact that it's not yet
finished these are just three of the
many aspect markers in Indonesian
another language without tenses is
Mandarin Chinese
I mentioned this in my video comparing
Chinese and Japanese but unfortunately I
messed up my explanation a little bit
here's the present tense sentence I gave
in that video
watch yourself this means I go to school
the verb Chi is the same no matter what
period of time it takes place in but
there are words that can be placed
before or after the verb which show
aspect what should i should I sell this
means I went to school la indicates the
perfective aspect viewing an action in
its entirety including its completion at
a point in time this is often thought of
as a past tense marker but in certain
contexts it can be used with future
events for example warming can cheela
funky need a deal wha this means I'll
call you after I've had a meal tomorrow
time can also be indicated with time
related vocabulary so again what
cheerless you so this means yesterday I
went to school you can see that we've
added the word for yesterday in this
sentence we actually still need the
perfective aspect marker because the
verb here is an action verb with a
definite start and finish but in some
sentences the perfective aspect marker
is not needed
for example so what you see you see this
means yesterday I rested here there's no
aspect marker and the only indication of
time is the word meaning yesterday
here's a sentence with a different
aspect marker
what's that she she saw the Lu Xiang
this means I'm on the way to school this
word sad shows imperfective aspect
indicating an action that is in progress
and again not necessarily in the present
and this part at the end here means on
the road
these are two common aspect markers in
Mandarin but there are others the main
thing to notice with the Indonesian and
Mandarin examples is that the verb
itself is not conjugated you simply
place a different word an aspect marker
next to the verb it's actually very
common for languages to not have tense
but I've never heard of a language that
doesn't have aspect in many languages
tense and aspect combined together to
form various verb conjugations and many
people really don't distinguish between
the two concepts for example in English
we have the present tense as in I work
and we have another form I'm working
which is in the present tense but with
progressive aspect and we have I have
worked which is in the present tense but
with perfect aspect showing a connection
between a past event and the present
people tend to think of all of these
different verb constructions as tenses
but strictly speaking there is more than
just tense there there are certain
languages that do have tenses but not
all of them in particular it's quite
common for languages to show no
distinction between present tense and
future tense this is the case with
Japanese for example which has two
tenses past and non past so cool today
must could mean I eat Japanese food in
the general sense or I'll eat Japanese
food in a specific case in the future
it's normally not hard to tell the
difference based on context and there's
another form day you do or Tomas which
represents a continuing action or
continuing state incorporating uses of
both progressive as well as perfect
aspect people often think this is
strictly a present tense form but it can
also be used for future actions for
example nice your name I got a lot well
kinda they say go to state or not they
change it on a night this sentence means
I can't believe that around this time
next week I'll already be living in
Canada here you can see that the verb
say katsu stay to
is in the toyota form representing
progressive aspect but the action takes
place in the future many linguists would
even argue that English has no future
tense that's because there are no
inflections on the main verb to show
future tense but it's shown instead
using a modal auxiliary specifically
will modal auxiliaries in general
indicate likelihood ability permission
and obligation will does express future
action but syntactically it works like a
modal auxiliary and there's also the
construction going to which can be
placed in front of the main verb to
indicate the future semantically
speaking English can express the meaning
of the future tense using these
constructions but grammatically they're
not really future tense but again most
people tend to think of that as the
future tense in English indeed many of
the verb forms that we tend to think of
as tenses include elements other than
tense take French for instance which is
usually thought to have 14 tenses 7
simple tenses and 7 compound tenses but
the 7 compound tenses contain an element
of aspect shown through the use of
auxiliary verbs and the conditional and
subjunctive forms show distinctions in
mood the conditional form suggests that
one action is dependent upon another and
the subjunctive form indicates desire or
probability
these are moods and even though they
have separate verb forms and are often
referred to as separate tenses they
really express both tense and mood so
verb tenses may work differently in
different languages and some languages
may lack grammatical verb tense entirely
but that doesn't mean that they can't
express those different time periods in
other ways whether from context from the
use of time expressions like tomorrow
from the use of aspect or from the use
of modal auxiliaries when some people
hear that there are languages with no
verb tense they imagine that the
speakers of these languages have no
understanding of time that they can't
plan for the future or that they can't
remember the past or something like that
but that's not the case at all we're all
humans after all and we all find ways to
communicate the same basic things the
question of the day does your language
have special verb forms to express past
present and future does your language
contain a large number of tenses that
incorporate aspect and mood if you're
not quite sure maybe look it up and find
out a little bit about it and tell us in
the comments down below be sure to
follow
focus on Facebook Twitter and Instagram
and once again thank you to all of my
amazing patreon supporters especially
these wonderful people right here on the
screen for their monthly pledges thank
you for watching and have a nice day
[Music]